there is something that is not working
some people decide not to see it what
not have the Parliament in Strasbourg
all the time countries in chaos are you
talking about Baghdad obviously it's my
job to put the other side Frances
president Emmanuel macron likes to be
seen as one of the driving forces for
reform in the EU but his efforts to
change his own country have run into
serious trouble
my guest this week here in Brussels is
his former Europe Minister Natalie
Russell one of his most vocal
cheerleaders in the European Parliament
is the macaron revolution advancing or
has it run out of steam
[Music]
[Music]
not only was Oh welcome to conflict zone
hello nobody has talked more about
reforming the EU than Emmanuel macron
why should anyone listen when he's
making such heavy weather of reforms in
his own country
well first he's been reforming France
for more than two years with a steady
path path the country's in chaos the
country is not in chaos
there is no strike anymore in railways
or public transportation and there will
be the most ambitious pension systems
reform for decades with which which we
pass in the parliament in the next few
weeks people have died in demonstrations
Paris has wreaked of tear gas for weeks
on end you've had gigantic disruptions
in transport some of the worst transport
disruptions since the 1960s are you
talking about offices I'm talking about
Paris you don't seem to come often to
Paris I do I have my family in Paris yes
there was some protest that's a French
tradition but there are 1700 people
injured across the country 1,700 and a
number of policemen injured among them
and some casualties we're due to this
yellowjacket protest movement you see it
throughout the world right now
middle class is wondering whether
globalization is good or bad for for
them and they need to get answers and
they got answers from the government
they got 17 billion euros program
dedicated at increasing wages and
increasing public services and they
found out that the president has an
increasingly authoritarian streak
doesn't he last year's report by the
National Ombudsman spoke of an
unprecedented number of preventive
arrests said that along with the decline
of public services a policy of
strengthened security and repression had
taken root there's a path for
accusations from the official watchdog
charged with defending the rights of
French citizens and I strongly deny it
we were in a democracy you think it
makes it up you think it makes it up I
well he three to say it and I would like
to ask other countries where people are
that free too good to protest or to deny
what's happening in the government if it
is not much good if you just dismiss it
when he says it this is my undermining a
fundamental I'm not in the government
I'm an elected member I have 23 elected
members of my party here in the European
Parliament I have as much freedom of
expression as any French citizen we are
in a democracy we're in a country where
we have rule of law every problem has
been or is being investigated with
independent judiciary I would love to
see it as open as balanced and with such
a rule of law in other places in the
European Union I think you should focus
on what's happening in Poland on what's
happening in Hungary rather we talk to
poles and Hungarians but we're talking
to you about France and you're still a
member of the president's party on March
after one of his most vocal cheerleaders
so that's why I'm putting these points
to you especially when both the UN and
the Council of Europe weighed in against
what they saw as disproportionate force
against demonstrators on the streets of
France there was disproportionate
violence in my country and there were
casualties caused by ruk blockades by
yellow vests should we forget about it
should we forget about the number of
trades of SMEs which closed because of
this unrest
I will never because I was elected by my
fellow citizens but you're not you're
not addressing the points that many
people have raised the Paris think-tank
for instance general SEO liebe said last
year the clamp down on civil liberties
was part of a consistent pattern since
Monsieur macro took office and I deny it
because there are freedoms they are
respected they are protected for
instance freedom to go on strike that's
fine that's even constitutional in my
country but free freedom not to go on
strike should be protected as well and
freedom of movement
protected as well you want to see hours
of police increased as they were in
October 2017 and new anti-terror laws
substantially increased police bars in
February 2018 the immigration will
reduced the rights of migrants and
asylum seekers in October that year the
Supreme Court refused to halt the
creation of a biometric database
containing detailed information of all
French citizens as surveillance and
these are measures that are causing
concern one prominent lawyer and
longtime supporter actually of Monsieur
macro Francoise Sewell but it bluntly
said fundamental rights are under attack
well I know mr. Sahu quite well I know
the NGO he is dealing with on refugees
because I'm dealing myself on a private
basis on the rights of refugees but
please fighting against terrorism the
first freedom of my fellow citizens is
security and my country was struck again
and again by terrorist attacks should we
say as we were before and say we are
doing nothing this is not nobody asked
you to do nothing just see not only to
undermine fundamental rights and
liberties that's now not denied you can
always go to the courts and you always
have your rights protected I know what
my fellow citizens want they want
security more than rights more than from
their own words they want both of them
and we protect both of them does
Monsieur McConnell believe he can have
greater success on the European stage
with reforms than he's had at home I
mean time after time he proclaims the
need for new organizations in the EU but
it's a bit like picking random tickets
out of a hat isn't it reforms to
immigration defense trade a European
agency to protect democracy European
Council for interior security European
climate bank and the reaction from the
rest of Europe was resolving silence to
these proposals um I'm not sure we are
talking about the same word about my
country or about Europe you're obviously
very entire macron that's so right
that's a surprise because I thought that
was fair journalism but it is not that's
your right all right it's mine it's my
job to put the other side to you you're
a macro supporter and putting
other side to you that's the way you see
things that not necessarily the way
other people see journalism but that's
your right I don't you know it is your
right to that to versus right let's go
to reforms in France yes they are
working we are the second most
attractive country in the European Union
for foreign investors we have one of the
highest growth rates in the European
Union we have the number of unemployed
which is decreasing steadily you have
three times the unemployed number of
Germany that's right but we don't have
many jobs when we talk about jobs which
we talk about jobs will full pay that's
a choice and we are still fighting
against unemployment and we are changing
the rules for apprentice for instance
and it is working and considering the
European Union
you mentioned the climate bank this was
something I was campaigning in for in
favor of when I was the head of the list
of kinesins in the European Union
election and now this isn't a program of
mrs. von der Leyen
her new green deal includes European
climate bank includes thousand billion
euros in the coming seven years to
finance green projects so this is
precisely what we have we're advocating
for and this is precisely what the
European Union's in getting committed to
but there was a huge backlash against
your climate proposals wasn't there when
the yellow vests protested against the
new carbon tax which was introduced to
try to get motorists to change their
behavior people in rural areas said it
was deeply unfair and the tax had to be
abandoned throughout Europe you have
claims for a more pro environment and
more anti global warming policy and at
the same time people say not in my
backyard
not on my fuel expenses we face it every
single developed country which is
raising attacks we have abandoned
raising attacks but we are working with
the
in union with the Commission on a
mechanism providing for protection of
European companies compared to third
country companies if they don't respect
the same environment rules they should
pay for the difference there is no
reason to impact all companies for new
regulations that we are choosing on
erroneous but your independent advisory
council on climates its report last June
strongly suggested your record today
didn't match the promises you've made ah
tell me of one one single European
country matching the result with the
promises every country is a tragedy and
one answer of it and that's why I'm in
this European Parliament is a European
answer we couldn't we cannot have one
member state taking decisions and
another going on a different path we
have to take common objectives and abide
by them we have to have objective float
for 2030 for 2050 and we are in the
process of doing it
madam Rosa if you were serious about the
environment you would hold this
incredibly wasteful process of convening
the European Parliament for one week
every month in Strasbourg and the rest
of the time in Brussels what you have
the Parliament in Strasbourg all the
time are you agree I mean you know but
at the moment this is hugely damaging
for the environment and hugely costly to
the European taxpayer but it's France's
vanity project isn't it it's in the
treaties and it's Germans vanity
projects you have the European Central
Bank in Frankfurt and it's Luxembourg
vanity project you have premises in
Lexington but the whole European
Parliament doesn't get up like a
traveling circus as some people have
said and once every month at a cost of
of a hundred thousand one hundred
million euros a year have you assess the
cost of having premises in Luxembourg in
Frankfurt and in many other places in
Europe that doesn't justify this does it
to specific do you want do you want
bureaucrats to stay in brussels bubble
cut from the realities of the ground cut
from member states is it what you want
is it what citizens have been voting for
no there are challenges please go to
member states please get out of this
boat
these go to Strasbourg once a month
they're not telling you that are they in
my country this is in you but but at the
cost of between listening to my voters
between 11,000 and 19,000 tons of extra
co2 emissions every year just to make
this stunt possible you know every time
you don't load a program on your
smartphone you are participating in
carbon emissions and still you're doing
it yes we will have to change our habits
but why are you finger pointing the
heart of European democracy where we
have the Council of Europe well we have
the you open court right you don't need
to go to Strasbourg once a month yes we
can stress the European conservatives
and reformists group said it was time
for any peace to get their own house in
order and the Traveling Circus no
organization can honestly claim to be
serious and tackling climate change and
still maintain a work of working which
is so manifestly destructive to the
environment conservative group also
notices that Poland one of its main
supporters is far as lagging far behind
in terms of emission and still denying
the need for a green new deal let's talk
about foreign policy Emmanuel macron
foreign policy because there's been a
strong perception that he favors go it
alone diplomacy instead of the
multilateral initiatives that he always
claims to value one of your presidents
harshest critics here in Brussels the
green mep fille blumburtt used him of
being drunk on power and said you don't
shape europe by bullying europe you
shape europe by building alliances this
is what we saw in increase
decades vivid lively Europe well
listened to on the world stage it was so
obvious that we were weighing in that we
were united and efficient come on you
are now united on Russia your policy on
Russia
come on Russia look at the Normandy
format summits that we had in Paris a
few weeks ago what did we do we defended
Ukraine's rights we favored an exchange
of prisoners which had not taken place
for months and years and we are fully in
line with the European position on
Ukraine Crimea Donbass and the rest just
Council on Foreign Relations said a lot
of people claimed that Monsieur macaron
didn't even inform them ahead of time
when he sent his foreign and defense
ministers to Moscow last September it
seemed to be part of an emerging pattern
of unilateral actions you say the same
one Angela Merkel goes to Moscow to meet
with Vladimir Putin no they are playing
their role France is an important member
state of the European Union France has a
permanent seat in the Security Council
we have responsibilities we defend
European values we carry European voice
and we have shared European positions we
are fully in line with Rosa Burrell
there is not the depth of a slice of
paper between what rosette barrel is
advocating for and what we are pushing
for bilaterally it strengthened Europe
it doesn't weaken it must wonder whether
when mr. Albin prefers to talk to Putin
or to talk to Aragon and says that the
Hungarian commissioner is at the service
of Azerbaijan wonder whether he supports
European Union policy last August mr.
macron called for new architecture in
Europe based on trust and security
because he said the continent would
never be stable with that easing and
clarifying Europe's relations with
Russia what he didn't spell out was how
you base a new relationship with Russia
on trust and security when there isn't
any how do you suggest he does that we
are vigilant my political party was
hacked by Russian activists during the
president
or campaign when there was a chemical
attack in Salisbury in the UK who was
pushing the other Europeans for a
coordinated answer it was a manual
Michael and no one else we are perfectly
aware of the threats of Russia nostalgic
of the past but then we would change
geography what do we prefer to have
Russia turning definitely to China which
ought to have Russia engaged in a
dialogue with the european union
concessions does that involve
it doesn't into a country that bulldozes
international borders shoots down
commercial aircrafts and as you say
since its assassins to europe well
murder foreign chemical weapons for
instance I would have preferred not to
see the knot string to protect support
it so heavily by Germany because it's
deepens or dependency on Russian gas
that's a problem and we have said it and
Emmanuel macron said it very bluntly
it's not a question of concessions it's
a question of having whole or voice
heard is it a consistent voice though if
we look at the question of enlargement
in the European Union for instance in
August
see macro was the leader who told Europe
to reinvest geographically in the West
Balkans warning that if it didn't the
fate of that region could be decided by
the US Russia and Turkey and then just
two months later he effectively blocked
or at the very least delayed those
countries from joining the EU doesn't
fit does it it's contradiction it's not
the first time that he blocked I blocked
it myself
a year before both you can tell yes
protecting from from these other
countries that are taking an interest in
the West Balkans and then not true I'm
seeing leadership look at Serbia Serbia
started its accession process did Serbia
distance itself from Russia not a second
do you think that accession negotiations
are the magical recipe to have countries
distancing themselves from Russia look
at Hungary
it has not worked we have to reassess
the whole accession negotiation process
it was not working we want to turn a
blind eye and just consider that we have
a policy when we have only bureaucracy
now we have to have be serious I'm dead
serious about the importance of a
European perspective for Western Balkans
and because I believe in it I don't want
it to leave it to bureaucrats I want to
be deeply involved in what we ask these
countries what to what we take them
accountable waterflow fight against
corruption fight against organized crime
I understand that but the Council on
Foreign Relations European Council for
relations said your French action may
have actually weakened the --use
leverage in this region French veto of
north Macedonians Albanians accession
negotiations has significantly changed
the context for resolving bilateral
problems in the West Balkans once again
look at Serbia they are in the process
they are negotiating they are opening
chapters and closing chapters and they
are closer than ever to Moscow there is
something that is not working some
people decide not to see it we decided
to name it because we want to reform it
if we are serious about enlargement and
we are serious it's not just a slogan
it's not just to play nice and then go
to some countries and try to make
business it's about you give with one
hand and then take with the other it's
being in having them ready to enter the
European Union and not being a failure
and not endangering the European project
tell me about the rumblings in the our
marsh party because they've been some
signs of serious discontent haven't
there two months ago the more reported
that G Lozada
presidented the Amish group in the
chamber had written two macro warning
about the state of his parliamentary
majority and pushing him to rebuild
trust with rank-and-file MPs serious
issue and the president said an MP's
don't trust him is not if it were the
case that would be a serious issue and
there are many examples throughout the
European Union of which coalition with
weak political parties absence of
majorities are very natural majority you
have one member state in European Union
which doesn't face this problem and this
is France there is a clear big strong
majority there is but by the end of it
in November 11 MPs in the National
Assembly had quit or being pushed out of
the parliamentary Association
parliamentary group in the summer 60 are
marched out because they were out of the
principles and values of the other
parties and this is healthy so party
discipline is breaking down in the
summer 60 are Marsh MPs abstained or
voted against the government over the
free trade agreement with Canada watch
me one single draft bill which was not
voted by the majority since 2017 to put
me just one there is no you've got an
official party candidate in the race for
mayor of Paris in March
Benjamin grieve oh and another are Marsh
MP cédric Villani who's decided he's
going to run anyway despite failing to
get official backing it's a mess isn't
it North Korea agree we are not Russia I
agree we are a free country with freedom
in political parties whether I agree
with Cedric Ville I need for running
where there is better America the answer
is no but he's free and thank God we are
in a free country and losing the youth
vote as the elections in for the
European Parliament showed no we didn't
there had never been as many young
people voting and a number of them voted
for Amash well compared to 2017 you lost
six percent among 18 to 24 year olds and
11 points among voters aged 25 to 34 the
problem is that you should compare what
is comparable compared it who is
previous European election and you will
see that the turnout was much bigger and
young people went to the polls where
they were not voting for previous
European elections at the highest score
in the European elections and the
categories was in the category of people
over 70 years old now but no party can
be complacent about that can they
we are a party which was created out of
strap scratch in 2016 and we are a party
which when the presidential
action the national election and we fare
well in the European election we are
going to have 23 any piece in this
Parliament exactly the same number as
the far-right I would have preferred to
have even more than that but compared to
my predecessors I'm quite proud of the
result but a party that came to power
representing above all the younger
poorer more metropolitan sectors of
society decent caring about climate no
wasn't that wasn't that the country it's
a party that denies the traditional
left-right divide and rightly so
look at where a traditional right and
traditional left are today in France and
it's true throughout Europe you're about
to take a position in the parliaments
steering brexit steering group well it's
to be it's going to be UK coordination
group yes can you get a deal in 11
months well ah not on everything a
bare-bones deal probably yeah you could
have done a deal with Theresa May why
didn t you do that you would have had a
softer brexit in remember grass on the
Irish backstop but because it's keen
that finished her off didn't it well she
had no majority in her Parliament but
she could have got an agreement sir if
you'd let her on the back stop used to
really think that protecting the rights
for companies or for citizens protecting
peace in Ireland was not a key priority
I don't agree with you our government
said it was a key priority but the
backstop wasn't necessary but you're
going to end up now with a with an
outcome if if Britain leaves without a
deal that's an outcome that nobody wants
especially the brain yeah but you didn't
want it either
no but it's going to cause massive
disruption for you - my point is you
player voice it's a choice for the Brits
they want to destroy their country I
don't think this is what they want they
have to be responsible leaders it's time
for responsibility seems kind of suffer
- that's for sure
I mean there's no good present drugs it
is bad whatever form it has but
protecting the rights of a
company's protecting your priorities
protecting the European project is key
they have chosen in Britain to get out
of the European Union fair enough
we have now chosen to just to destroy
the European Union on all side and we
will note that's a reversal thank you
very much for your confidence
[Music]
you
[Music]